these three brothers risked their lives
working the fields of Southern Ukraine
Russian forces have retreated from what
the Ukrainian Army says are dozens of
villages and settlements it is liberated
in this area
but as the Ukrainian counter-offensive
continues towards the russian-occupied
city of kirstan so do the dangers for
Farmers near the front line
when the shelling starts we hide we
search for holes to run to the danger is
everywhere bombs can drop at any time
there are a lot of unexploded bombs it's
very frightening knowing we can tread on
or drive over one
so in the last few minutes the guys have
found this in the field that they're
working in it is a cluster bomb delivery
system it carries tens of individual
bomblets that spread out over a Target
area and can remain hidden and deadly in
fields like this for years
neither Russia nor Ukraine the
signatories of the 2008 International
Convention on cluster Munitions that
aims to ban their use
the Farm's combine harvester recently
hit what the men believe was a mine
Ukrainian Army blew up Ordnance in a
controlled explosion close by
Ukrainian helicopter gunships fly low
over the Farms towards their Enemy Lines
God bless our boys says Galia as they
pass overhead
she describes the day a Russian soldier
came to her home
gun behind him I told him I wished he
could return home alive and give his
mother grandchildren I turned and went
inside and cried in my kitchen my whole
body was shaking I thought he would
shoot me in the back I was utterly
terrified
homes in liberated Villages destroyed
Bridges blown up supply lines cut
the black heads of dried sunflowers bow
under the blue Autumn sky like an Army
in retreat
Ukrainian soldiers are in control here
now but as the farmers harvest the
remaining crop they hope the Russian
army never returns
Charles Stratford Al Jazeera Southern
Ukraine